- [Instructor] Hello, grammarians,
let's talk about personal pronouns,
but first let me lay
some sentences on you.
Jake and I baked a loaf of bread.
We baked a loaf of bread.
You can learn anything.
My friends are cool.
They are cool.
Now I'm gonna circle a few of these words,
so the ones I wrote in yellow,
and point them out to you.
I, we,
you, my, they,
these are personal pronouns.
They're pronouns that change
depending on how you're using them.
On whether you're using them
as the object of a sentence,
as the subject to show
ownership, and so on.
But we'll get to those in later videos.
For now, I'm gonna talk about
the three basic types of English pronoun.
Broadly speaking, there
are pronouns about me,
pronouns about you,
and pronouns about
something or someone else.
This is an idea called grammatical person.
Pronouns about me are first person,
pronouns about you are second person,
and pronouns about
something or someone else
are third person.
So, when I say I love my dog, Phryne.
I is a first person pronoun.
In the sentence,
she is an excellent dog,
where she subs out for Phryne,
she is a third person pronoun.
Here is a picture of Phryne,
I think we can all agree, she is perfect.
Thank you.
Okay. So what I want to do here
is fill out this table
with some of the basic pronouns
we use to talk about ourselves
divided between singular,
that is one person,
and plural, or more than one person.
Some first person pronouns
are I, me, my, and mine.
But what if there's more than one of me?
What if I'm part of a group
and I wanna refer to that group?
Well, then I'd use a plural pronoun
like we, us, our, or ours.
Second and third person are interesting
because they have pronouns
that pull double duty.
In second person,
the singular and plural are identical.
Singular second person
is you, your, and yours.
And plural second person is the same,
you, your, and yours.
That is to say, it's
the same whether or not
you're referring to one
person, here in singular,
or many people, here in plural.
Understanding whether you meet one you
or a plural you depends on context.
And it's usually very easy to figure out.
Third person pronouns belong
to the most crowded category
because the world is
full of things and people
who are neither me nor you.
For singular pronouns we
have she, her, and hers,
he, him, and his,
they, them, their and theirs
and it, and its.
They, like you, can refer
to both a single person
or multiple people,
but it doesn't specify a
gender like she and he do.
This is extremely useful.
I'd take note that the word it
only refers to inanimate objects
and sometimes non-human animals,
but never to people.
A robot? Yes.
A person? Not so much.
Now, in the plural category, much simpler,
we have they, them, their, and theirs.
Similar to singular versus plural you
singular versus plural
they depends on context
and it'll be obvious
from the words around it
which one you mean.
This is a lot of information to swallow.
Pause this if you need to practice saying
the different pronouns aloud,
do the exercises on the
Khan Academy site or app.
This is not the only time I'll be talking
about personal pronouns in this course.
So we have an opportunity to go deeper,
especially if you want to
know more about the history
of the singular use of
they, which is super cool.
In the meantime,
please enjoy this second
image of my dog, Phryne,
who is, again, as I said, a perfect dog.
You can learn anything.
David out.